you have two stepkids and right do I
have steps okay and would you say that
you are involved are you like a very
involved stepmom or not so involved I'm
kind of involved
they're both registered to vote I made
sure of that okay the only problem is
they're 11 and 12 I know no but okay so
yes we they're 18 and 22 actually 22
today happy birthday Emily but I well
when they were younger I was a little
bit more involved obviously and I
remember you kind of have to be yeah
because you they have you have to be
around them all the time you have to
watch them all the time near them I told
my friend once I was gonna have to stay
home and babysit and she was like it's
not babysitting when it's your own kid
yeah that's true parent that's called
parent yeah yeah so I learned that I'm
stepmom again you know I learned these
things late but one time we were
watching a movie together
and my stepdaughter was like really
infatuated with the lead actress she
thought she was so talented and
wonderful and and she said like how come
that girl's not a movie star how come
she's not more famous and I said because
she got pregnant in high school and had
to quit acting forever
but that was a lie because I just really
thought maybe that would you know you
lied to her and make that up I lied um
you know I call it parenting I was
trying to think quick on my feet and try
to make a learning moment out of this
and so I don't think you're supposed to
do that I don't think you're supposed to
say well you never lie to your kids it's
different when I do to your kids
absolutely yeah yeah they think Andy
left for the army two years ago
I shoulda tried that one yeah but that's
pretty like you were trying to make a
little bit of a life lesson but by
slandering this actress yeah yeah yeah
yeah I did and then that was a long time
ago and wasn't the case with the actress
by the way but I thought maybe like it
just kind of came out of me I didn't
even it just came out like you know
you're an uninhibited person aren't you
yeah seem that way like you just whoa I
feel that we talked once it was just
during the commercial break but I
thought I should bring that up next time
you're on you said that you have that
you swear a lot Oh
what did you what you're thinking of at
that time you said you found me
attractive well I did I do swear a lot I
I've been trying to substitute words for
swear word so I've been saying farts a
lot lately instead of the other F word
and and and that's been going well it's
not like fudge or something more
pleasant y-yeah I like the word I like
saying farts it feels it feels peppy
yeah yeah you say anything like that
it's peppy Black Plague you know I mean
you know look they're just loving it you
can sell anything that way yeah they
love it well my husband was irritated a
little that I didn't do that when the
kids were younger
and a few years ago did you swear around
a lot around them when they were young
yes I was terrible and I did try some
substitutions but it just never really
stuck and we even tried one Christmas
well for New Year's our resolution we
were gonna do competing swear jars we
had a jar with Dean and a jar with Judy
and then every time you swore you put a
quarter in it and then the idea
obviously is to at the end of the year
have the least amount of quarters but
you know really cool keeps their New
Year's
twenty-five dollars a breakout
you